I swear I'm a better boyfriend than I
imagined a bread maker for sure I hope I
am welcome to cookie kitchen today we're
gonna be decorating gingerbread men in
our ideal man form I think I'm gonna do
a spin on it so it's not gonna be my
ideal man but it's more gonna be what
happens to a man in New York City I'm
gonna go with like a post-impressionism
approach you know what you're gonna do
no but I think I'm just gonna use my
iPhone and just like Google some photos
okay I was gonna be creative but it's
fine you just start yes okay I'm gonna
start with the hair it's important I'm
gonna go do an unconventional approach
that friday-night approach oh this is
gonna be interesting cuz I have not done
this in ever probably forever this is
actually my first time we'll see how
this turns out I'm just gonna give you
like your basic smiley go lucky kind of
like how an ideal man trapeze smiley and
go lucky but some swoosh right there
yeah you need to calm down that's gonna
be awesome just keep eating your cookie
okay I think I'm gonna make mine like an
80s exercise guy really into exercising
and working out and getting sweaty why
not
I'm still chewing on this by the way
maybe I'm gonna give him mine like a
garland like scarf situation and you can
I could probably like cut some off and
then put some on the neck look at maybe
artsy crafty I love it I get really
competitive when it comes to like crafty
things oh it's on I'm not sure if this
is an 80s workout Gingerman
anymore it's more like Serena Williams
but I it's just who wouldn't want to buy
to that we always end we always end up
competing every time see what happens
here oh I shouldn't have done that I'm
not good at this well chasing everything
oh yeah doing more of that that a
abductor I like the classic approach
though so I like my guy classic with a
little bit of an edge - hence the
missing half of his face you can't eat
that though I don't care
look you guys I'm really nailing this
like for someone who's never done this
before
look coach I love yours cold Redwyne
when I eat my entered rent man I'm gonna
want them to taste good so the more
sugar no better are we doing the big
reveal the big reveal
do you like a term wall oh I'm not done
one two three
this one's mine this was mine my Richard
Simmons inspired gingerbread man thank
you I'm impressed with that what happens
to you after you enter the New York City
dating pool you literally give you the
line and I did Kylie Minogue I
definitely think I went like completely
just like tangent not well I want my
ideal man to be even about you but I
think this is really therapeutic for me
yeah I clearly won mine isn't
necessarily my ideal man but like
definitely fit look at those sweat bands
I kind of still wear those today I love
the movement because you can really see
the emotional journey
oh now I like the hair no good ideas
right see he was hating on my side swoop
but it's good I wouldn't call that a
slide suit might call that like a
cinnamon roll swirl maybe that'll be my
drag name for popping that gingerbread
man cherry I guess I feel like it was a
success I think they make a really good
couple and it might still didn't mess up
so boom I'm glad that I could be here
for your first gingerbread experience
mine's a little destroyed now but you
know it's all about the fun and the
character mm-hmm and I'd say there's a
lot of Bo and Matt's how the cookie
crumbles that's how the cookie crumbles
that's how his cookie crumbles mine
doesn't buy
[Applause]